universes Collide in more ways than one
in the new spider-verse movie and it
definitely doesn't happen the way you
might expect warnings spoilers ahead for
Spider-Man across the spider-verse
seeing as how the spiderverse follow-up
originally had a part 1 as part of its
title it's no surprise It Ends by
setting up another sequel but the film
has wide-ranging implications for the
future of other Spider-Man projects too
the movie contains many references to
Spider-Man projects of the past both
hand-drawn and live action viewers also
get to see Clips but not new material
from Toby Maguire and Andrew Garfield's
versions of the character there's even a
moment where the spot travels to the
Venom Universe speaking to Mrs Chen for
a little bit
so however arguably one of the best
surprises from the film is when miles
gets a tour of Spider-Man 2099's
compound and gets taken to an Area
Housing classic Spider-Man villains who
ended up in the wrong Universe there are
many great gags in this sequence
including a moose version of Mysterio
but fans will likely be most taken with
a surprise Cameo from Donald Glover as a
live-action version of Prowler complete
with costume while this version of
Prowler could have come from anywhere in
the Multiverse fans won't forget that
Glover already played Prowler Alter Ego
Aaron Davis and Spider-Man homecoming a
lot of time has passed between that
movie and now so it's possible he went
from a low-level criminal to a full-on
super villain suggesting a viable path
for the next live-action movie with Tom
Holland Spider-Man producer Amy Pascal
recently hinted that a live-action Miles
Morales project is in the works without
further details it's impossible to say
whether this would be part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe or something separate
within Sony's wheelhouse but Donald
Glover's Cameo and across the
spider-verse could hint at a storyline
coming within the MCU Pascal also
revealed that Spider-Man 4 with Tom
Holland is in the pipeline so it's
possible miles and Aaron could have a
story together in that film I don't want
those weapons in this neighborhood I got
a nephew who live here while Holland's
Peter Parker would likely have a larger
adversary to deal with Glover's uncle
Aaron could factor into the story
somehow bringing Peter and miles into
contact with one another if Marvel
wanted to keep the focus on Peter Parker
it's possible miles and Aaron would only
play smaller roles with Miles getting
bit by The Spider and facing the death
of his uncle in his own Standalone film
or we could see miles undergo the
beginnings of his character Arc in
Spider-Man 4 before spinning off into
another movie similarly to how Tom
Holland initially came onto the scene in
Captain America Civil War before
appearing in his first Solo movie then
again Glover's appearance in across the
spider-verse may just function as a bit
of fan service and nothing more more
details on Spider-Man 4 and Beyond
probably won't materialize until after
the writer's strike is over so for now
fans can only speculate and that's when
the World Went Crazy Donald Glover has
an intriguing history with Spider-Man
and even partly inspired the creation of
Miles Morales so him popping up and
across the spider verse is a great Cameo
for more reasons than one when a
Spider-Man film franchise was being
rebooted with the Amazing Spider-Man
Glover half jokingly campaigned to snag
the role of Peter Parker even showing up
with Spider-Man pajamas in an episode of
community the role ultimately went to
Andrew Garfield but Glover did something
arguably even more important Brian
Michael Bendis and artist Sarah bakelli
were working on the Ultimate Spider-Man
comic when Glover inspired them to
really create a black Spider-Man Bendis
even told USA Today I saw him in the
costume and thought I would like to read
that book so I was glad I was writing
that book Glover even voiced miles for
two episodes of 2015's Ultimate
Spider-Man cartoon as such it was
appropriate casting to bring him into
the MCU as miles uncle Aaron the
creative team behind Spider-Man far from
home even considered bringing Glover
back for a brief role but it just didn't
pan out fortunately Glover's cameo in
across the spider verse suggests the
character could still be out there and
if there's anyone who should help Usher
Miles Morales into a live-action setting
it should definitely be Donald Glover